bonjour a tous des gi's mettre à jour
trois produits dont le fameux mavic pro
avec une nouvelle version qui s'appelle
le mavic pro platinum
[Musique]
je suis secret pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ma chaîne parle de
stratégie youtube et de tous les
produits d'affluence qui vous aident à
réussir sur youtube qui vous accompagne
dans votre vie numérique et notamment
les drones
si vous voulez en savoir plus pour
réussir votre chaîne et pour connaître
l'actualité ces produits vous invite à
vous abonner à la chaîne comme ça vous
ne manquerez aucune publication dj hi
c'est probablement la boîte qui a
démocratisé les drones pour le grand
public avec le fantôme 3 le fantôme 4 le
nas vite le spaf et plein d'autres
produits catalogue ce fameux grand
public d'avoir de nombreux produits pour
réussir leurs vidéos alors si vous êtes
créateur contenu vous connaissez
forcément les brawn de dj hi
ils ont une renommée ils sont vraiment
super facile à prendre en main à piloter
et on peut faire des vidéos d'une
qualité exceptionnelle d'ailleurs tout
est en train de filmer mois avec un
produit de dj hype c'est l'osm au plus
je vous invite d'ailleurs allez le
découvrir ici un excellent produit
permis de faire bonne vidéo et sur
lequel voyez on peut se voir en fonction
monitoring certaines choses enfin c'est
vraiment un truc qui est vraiment
topissime est justement dj am vient de
sortir une nouvelle version de son magic
trop le mavic pro platinum liasse mavic
pro platinum qui veulent sortir
il ya aussi une nouvelle version du
fantôme quatre pros le fantôme quatre
pro occident
et un nouveau mode de pilotage pour le
spark mais sans leur parlera un peu plus
tard j'ai pu rencontrer l'équipe de dj à
berlin lorsque je suis allé à l'ifa
c'est du vol et les drones et je peux
vous assurer qu'ils sont vraiment
exceptionnelles vous allez vous faire
une idée par vous même c'est le mavic
trop platinum qui ont assorti à l'ifa ya
trois jours d'accord
l'avantagé du magic au platinium par
rapport
la version originale c'est que en fait
selon vous l'entendez il est très
silencieux avec 60 % d'émissions sonores
en moins
et maintenant de voile aussi amélioré de
11 ensemble qui le portent aujourd'hui à
30 minutes vol 1
en outre 27 minutes pour la version si
vous avez changé la vie active avec un
pager changer la batterie en fait on a
travaillé on a amélioré le
le contrôleur de vitesse électronique
d'accord et les hélices aussi qu'ils ont
été modifiées l'aérodynamisme des
hélices
ok donc les deux conques
voilà on peut presque plus et c'est
super c'est vrai que l'appréciable
ce produit la luz malik pro est un peu
plus cher que l'ancienne version
j'imagine il est un peu plus cher il est
à 100 euros
bref aujourd'hui à 1299 euros et la
version originale et 1199 euros
vous pouvez commander aujourd'hui ouais
il est dit dans le livre est disponible
aujourd'hui à la commande gérable
livrables jeu français les premières
commandes doit régler en surtemps dites
moi ce que vous en pensez
dites moi quel rôle vous utilisez si
vous envisagez d'en prendre en l'avenir
oui non si oui lequel
un dj ait une autre mac vous parlez tout
ça en commentaire et moi je me ferai un
plaisir de discuter avec vous vous
invite à vous abonner à la chaîne pour
en savoir toujours plus sur maul
stratégie youtube et pour découvrir tous
les produits qu'il vous faut pour
réussir et les premiers influence est
produit est plus sympa du moment si vous
avez des questions vous pouvez me
rejoindre sur twitter @ monsieur re et
avec le hashtag ask monsieur heureux
quant à moi je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous dis à très
bientôt pour nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
portez vous bien
salut
[Musique]